mis aux états unis la suite du procès de
zacarias moussaoui ce sont maintenant
des proches des victimes du 11-septembre
qui sont entendu des témoignages inédits
ont été diffusées il replonge le pays
tout entier dans l'effroi les attentats
contre les tours alain de chalvron aaron
dimon sur place aux pleurs on pleure
beaucoup au septième étage du tribunal
d'alexandria
le procureur avait promis de l'émotion
promesse tenue
le procès revis long septembre au
travers de bandes sonores inédites comme
celle ci c'est kevin cosgrove bloqué
dans une des tours du world trade center
il est en communication avec les
urgences la bande-son s'arrête là la
tour vient de s'effondrer
mélissa deuil est également prisonnière
du cheveu au 83e étage paniquer le
tribunal a vu également défilé des
témoins ces lits hansson qui a perdu sa
petite fille son fils et sa belle fille
dans le vol 175 de unitaid
il était au téléphone avec son fils au
moment de l'impact de l'avion avec la
tour ne t'inquiète pas papa ça ne sera
pas long oh mon dieu ce sont ses
derniers mots liane sonne suivez tout
cela en même temps à la télévision
la présidente du tribunal est obligé de
prévenir
trop d'émotions peut nuire à la
neutralité des jurés et nourrir un appel
houssaoui lui ricane devant ce cirque
macabre hollywoodien fin de citation
à partir de jeudi ce sera au tour des
témoins de la défense de passer à la
barre ils auront fort à faire pour
renverser l'impact émotionnel de ces
dernières audiences